ladies and gentlemen boys and girls my
goodness it is almost midnight when we
are shooting this right now because we
saw this came out we're like no no we
have to get our tickets first and
foremost there were four of us on the
job running about eight different
devices between phones and computers and
after almost two hours we finally
managed to get tickets for thursday
december 16th for spider-man no way
[Music]
still doesn't feel real i know it
doesn't i'm waiting for the servers to
retroactively crash i was so upset we
were all like you think after two years
they would have updated their systems
started coming out a little bit early on
our side earlier than they said it would
and then within 10 minutes it was like i
just keep getting checked out every time
i go to the checkout boot up boot it out
it's on the pre-blip servers wow that
was uh that was intense anyway we got a
really short spot that they put out i'm
assuming something about tickets being
on sale but of course we gotta check it
out it's a spider-man no way home tv
spot let's see what they got here
[Music]
tickets on sale now dude
tickets on sale now
i actually wonder i wonder if they
pulled that from a real scene like he he
like he's on the phone with ned dude
everyone knows mysterious cereal blew my
cover he blew my cover dude dude he's
getting so caught up talking ned's
calling him and then zendaya's like dude
that's a lot that they would have had to
have shot just to have any tickets on
sale things unless they just adr over
something else
that's another thing too yeah it almost
feels like it could be a real moment
from them like since that seems like a
humorous way to have them interact with
the news especially on the heels of it
being revealed in them you know out for
a swing i mean that's what two guys
would do right yeah so we would say dude
dude
sound dude
[Music]
that is our life so i imagine that they
would probably be doing the same thing
too you got a little bit of goblin
laughing here too but you got a little
moment too with doc hawks saying catch
yeah he's about to throw tickets to pay
yeah yeah yeah
there's tickets for all you freaks out
the only two available seats in the city
made me think of spider-man 2 on the
train fight when he's throwing people at
him like catch you know yeah
it's a little bit of the vibe that i was
getting love this tickets on sale now
that's just like when amc decided to
email us tickets on sale now we got that
email alert i'm like yeah we know yeah
we've been trying for 15 minutes now
i thought you were about to get this
like five minutes in advance
or at least right on the point of sale
not an hour later gosh anyway cute
little tv spot enjoyed it as always any
little glimpse we can get i find very
enjoyable thank you guys so much for
being here thank you guys so much for
support hopefully you guys got your
tickets too comment down below what your
ticket buying experience was like hey
we'll catch you guys soon